I'm Patrick many of your hosts devalue
tainment and I want to tell you about
what happened yesterday I was having
lunch with a friend at Rafi's place if
you haven't been to Rafi's place Paul
can we put a picture of Rafi's place and
a link on the bottom it's by far the
best Middle Eastern restaurant in
America you got to go to it if you
haven't been it's in LA Glendale
California anyways we were sitting there
talking and as we're sitting having a
conversation for me says hey Patrick so
you know what would you say is the
formula for wealth creation right what
is the formula for wealth creation hey
you know you have a bad card you have
this and you made millions of dollars I
thought the holy stuff he said so what
is the formula for creation the
conversation came out I'm taking out all
this stuff and and I so that's a pretty
good question you know I've been asked
that before and I got a very simple
three-step formula on how to create
wealth it's very simple for me here's
what I did okay so first thing you have
to do is you got to get a paper pen and
make a list of the most important skills
that you can learn whatever that skill
is write it down okay I'm gonna learn
how to play piano I'll learn how to draw
I'm going to learn how to cook I'm gonna
learn how to work on a car whatever it
is you write down different skill sets
and to me by far the most important
skills that I came up with is sales
period the Presidential Debates taking
place right on the Republican side and
you're hearing the left and the right
you're hearing Hillary Bernie Sanders
you know all these guys on the left that
getting up there saying hey you should
vote for me because I'm this I'm this
I'm that and you're seeing the right
Carson Rubio Cruz Huckabee Trump Jeb
Bush all these guys are getting up
saying why you ought to vote for me to
become a president right they're
campaigning but the number one skill
said if you think about the number one
skill set on why a person will vote for
somebody else is sales that person knows
how to sell Barack Obama know how to
sell a dream McCain had no idea how to
sell a dream you had no idea to sell
anything right Jimmy Carter didn't know
how to sell Ronald Reagan knew
to sell everything is about selling you
got a cell you got a cell and cast a
vision you got a cell selling is the
number one skill you gotta learn so for
me three step to become a wealthy number
one learn the skill set up sales and to
learn the skill set up sales there's a
lot of books you got to read I have 100
books to read for entrepreneurs I got
several them that are on my website Paul
can we put a link of the tap 100 books
for them to go to Mario let's put that
on the bottom as well if you go on the
bottom you click on it go and order all
the books on our website you'll see one
by one by one the ones that are in sales
okay so number one scalar sales so you
gotta learn the skill set of sales
second thing you have to do the second
thing I did is choose an industry so
what is an industry you choose to be a
part of right so now I wrote out on a
sheet of paper I had Show biotech and in
order to biotech I need to go do this
okay do I want to go out there and sell
you know pharmaceutical sales is that
what I want to sell I want to go out
sell technology they want to go sell
real estate I'm gonna go sell mortgages
I want to go sell there so I'm gonna go
sell you know Nutritionals tell you know
long distance boom I finally chose
financial industry within a financial
industry I got very specific to the life
insurance industry I'll tell you why I
chose this industry I was in New Orleans
two weeks ago we're at the the infamous
Bourbon
we're on Bourbon a Bourbon Street or
bourbon Boulevard whatever it is we're
at Bourbon you know which you know what
that place is a place where it's
sponsored by alcohol I don't know what
it is but everywhere smells like beer
and one of my one of my good friends
Matt he asked me question he says hey
Pat when you when you got into the
financial industry you got your serious
766 31:26 all this stuff why did you go
away from being a money manager to being
a insurance agent that's a very good
question this was my answer to him I
said look I have never in my life seen a
client cry and get emotional over me
getting him on a stock or a mutual fund
a 30 percent return I've never seen a
person get emotional it's more like hey
by the way mr. Jones you know your
mutual fund the 22 percent last year
market was great okay awesome that's
great news okay
I've never seen emotion it was just
that's it I'm just great news that
you're telling me this on the complete
opposite side I've never seen that much
emotion with a product being sold
when I hear a client to lose as a loved
one and you deliver a death benefit or
you see the family telling a story of
what happened to them when an insurance
policy was bought and how it changed
their lives I mean there's several
clients that we deal with one of my
friends sprink eatment can we put the
link of her video on the bottom this is
I mean try watching this video of spring
and I challenge you to not get emotional
watching it so the moment I went from
seeing the fact that this is all money
money money money money great there's
many ways to make money I wanted a part
of it to be crusade where my heart gets
connected to this one the reasons why I
love the military because to me I chose
the skill set sales the industry I chose
was insurance because I felt insurance
within a financial industry was the
Patriots of the financial industry
that's how I see it i see insurance
agents or the Patriots of the financial
industry because you know no one wants
to do it they need it everybody needs it
but no one wants or don't I chose to
take that route you can call it crazy
whatever but we chose an industry that
we got excited about it gives great paid
great renews it gives an incredible life
people who are in it for 10 years have
unbelievable lives who do the writer but
that's the industry I chose right step
number three so you choose the skillset
you choose the industry skill number
three is the people you want to run with
that's the next thing you got to figure
out you know one skill industry the
group of people you want to run with New
Jersey the group of people you want to
run with why is this so important very
simple because one common values common
principles common vision common goals
and when you're running with an
organization typically one of the
conversations I was done with the same
gentleman I was having lunch without
Rafi's place there was a frustration he
had because he's in a place that he is
exploding with ambition and he wants to
grow and do all this stuff and here's a
hundred something euro company that's
doing business
the old-fashioned way that's doing
business all we don't want to do this so
we don't want to change it so we don't
want to do that in there sit and run and
okay that's not how we do things we're
not used to social media we're not used
to videos all this a no no no no no no
you can't do that no you can't post that
up why not so to him there's friction
between him having so much Drive and he
can't do it you got to find the right
group of people the other side when
there's friction is the company is
thinking big the company has gone places
and then the person and it doesn't
necessarily have the desire to be that
ambitious and they kind of want to go on
cruise control and they don't want to be
challenged anymore they want to stay
there that's typically when you have the
relationship that well you get to choose
choose the skill write it down choose
the industry be specific with what
industry want to choose then find a
group of people you want to run with
common values common morals common
vision common things that they want to
do that challenges you to also get
better and all of us our next thing you
know you're you're creating wealth
you're making money you're doing great
things but believe me when I tell you
this skillset of sales is absolutely
important I wrote a book one time called
barbarians two bureaucrats by Lawrence
Miller I called them I said hey how come
this book is never sold
how come it's only got this many reviews
this is what even I said I'd like to buy
the book can i buy so you can buy the
book on Amazon
I'd like to buy your book because the
content in this thing is incredible in
this book when it explains the cyclical
cycles of a society organization a
company but the reason why this didn't
sell is because somebody didn't sell it
either he didn't sell it or the
publisher didn't sell it who's the
publisher Fawcett Columbine whatever it
didn't sell it somebody didn't sell it
this is one the best average a thousand
eleven hundred books this is one of the
best business books I've ever read
because the most important skill set to
learn is sales and when you put that
formula together you have a shot at
creating wealth based on how ambitious
you are and based on how much work you
think you put into it so my message of
the week um please be sure to subscribe
to the channel and if you got any
questions comment on the bottom thanks
for watching
you